معنا من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح
وسط قطاع غزه مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت
هشام قبل قليل شاهدنا صور مرعبه لحجم
الدمار والتجريف وحجم القصف والاشتباكات
في خان يونس في في اكثر من نقطه في خان
يونس ماذا عن هذه الاشتباكات والى اين
وصلت الاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره وربما
هناك عده محاور في قطاع غزه باتت
الاشتباكات فيها اكثر عنفا لا سيما في
المناطق الشرقيه لخان يونس الدبابات
الاسرائيليه ربما تتوغل شيئا فشيئا الى
بعض المناطق لكنها تعود لتتم وضع وتتمركز
في مناطق مختلفه وفي ربما خطوط خلفيه
وبالتالي الاشتباكات ما تزال مستمره في
اكثر من محور في محور مدينه خانيونس ربما
هو من المحاور الاكثر كثافه في هذه
الاشتباكات لا سما منطقه خزاعه في المناطق
الشرقيه لخان يونس هذه المنطقه باتت تتعرض
الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات من من المدفعيه
والاشتباكات فيها مستمره رغم كل هذه
عمليات القصف الاسرائيلي المتواصله في كل
لحظه في كل حين هناك انفجارات تسمع في تلك
المنطقه سواء الانفجارات الناجمه عن
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه التي تقصف هذه
المناطق وايضا الغارات الاسرائيليه
بالاضافه الى الانفجارات الناجمه عن اطلاق
القذائف من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وتفجير عبوات ناسفه والمقاومه ما بين فينه
واخرى ويوم واخر تعلن عن عمليات باتجاه
القوات الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
يونس لكن القصف من الجيش الاسرائيلي بات
عنيفا جدا وهناك طائرات مسيره باتت تطلق
النار على المواطنين الذين يحاولون العوده
الى منازلهم او حتى نازحون يحاولون الهرب
والبحث عن مكان امن كما في مخيم المغازي
القصف في مخيم المغازي ووسط القطاع ربما
هو الاكثر عنفا خلال هذه الساعات الماضيه
وخلال الايام الماضيه كذلك الجيش
الاسرائيلي يكثف من عملياته في وسط قطاع
غزه بعد ان بدا عمليه بريه
منطلقا من مخيم البريج وتوغل في بعض
المناطق في مخيم البريج لكنها حتى الان ما
زالت على اطراف هذا المخيم كذلك توغل على
اطراف مخيم المغازي وفصل حتى الشارع
الواصل ما بين مخيم المغازي ومخيم البريج
كانت هناك بعض الدبابات لكنها تراجعت
واعادت التموضع في اماكن مختلفه لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي مازال يطلق القذائف ويمنع حتى
المواطنين من الخروج وهناك قناصه اعتلوا
بعض المنازل ويطلقون النار على المواطنين
هناك شرات من الاصابات تصل في كل لحظه وفي
كل حين الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى من جراء
عمليات الاطلاق اطلاق النار المستمره على
هؤلاء المواطنين بعضهم يحاول النزوح من
مكان الى اخر بعضهم حتى يحاول ان يذهب الى
اجلاء عائلته او حتى انتشال بعض الجثامين
من المنازل التي استهدفتها الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه فيقص فهم الجيش
الاسرائيلي او يطلق عليهم النار من هذه
الطائرات المسيره التي باتت تحوم وتحلق في
سماء القطاع بكثافه وخاصه في المنطقه
الوسطى وفي قلب هذه المنطقه كما حدث في
الزوايده عندما اطلق الجيش الاسرائيلي
النار من هذه المسيرات على المواطنين وكان
هناك اكثر من 100 مصاب جراء هذا هذه
العمليات اطلاق النار ايضا مخيم النصيرات
يتعرض الى قصف عنيف في هذه اللحظات من قبل
المدفعيه من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه الطائرات نفذت سلسله من
الغارات على هذا المخيم استهدفت في جلها
منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه ايضا كان هناك عدد
من الشهداء وصلوا الى مستشفى العوده في في
مخيم النصيرات جراء استهدافهم في شارع
العشرين كذلك هناك منزل في المخيم الجديد
في مخيم النصيرات بالاضافه الى مواصله
الدبابات والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
اطلاقها لقذائف باتجاه المنازل في المخيم
الجديد وايضا في منطقه المغرا في منطقه
مدينه الزهراء وايضا كذلك في المنازل في
ارض المفتي وهناك عشرات من النازحين ال
متواجدين في تلك المناطق لكن رغم كل ذلك
يواصل الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليات اطلاق
النار والم المدفع الاسرائيلي على تلك
المناطق وبالتاكيد كل مناطق قطاع غزه
تتعرض ما بين الفينه والاخرى الى قصف من
قبل الطائرات او من قبل المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه هشام زقوت من خانيونس شكرا
جزيلا لك